thank you
okay
there are no planned fire drills so if
the alarm goes off please leave the
building in Northerly fashion through
the nearest fire exit please either use
the fire exit through the main doors of
the hall or the fire exit to the store
room adjacent to the stage the fire
assembly point is the island in front of
the main entrance to the building please
do not delay your evacuation to collect
any belongings please do not return to
the building until given permission to
do so by Council staff please note that
the meeting will be audio recorded
please switch off any mobile phone so
turn them to silent please note that the
toilet and hand washing facilities are
in the foyer area thank you
me too
so we're going to begin our time this
evening with some prayer so let us pray
almighty God we bring before you the
agenda for tonight's meeting that we who
have been entrusted with the
responsibility to govern and make
decisions for those who have elected us
be guided by the best of motives and
with the interests of all for the
benefit of all
give clear minds and the desire to hear
all points of view including those who
may be diametrically opposed to our own
for an openness of debate
make us gracious and courteous to friend
and opponent alike with a real sense of
working together for this district and
the areas that are represented by each
of our district councilors
at the same time we commend for your
blessing the work of all the employees
of Rochford District Council who
maintain Implement and make possible the
words that are debated discussed and
formed into policy amen
and we cannot help but in our United
Humanity be moved by some of the scenes
we have seen after the earthquake in
turkey and Syria
so let us now turn our thoughts to
prayers for those who have been affected
Heavenly Father our hearts are moved by
the effects of the earthquake in turkey
and Syria
the grief felt by families who have lost
loved ones or await news of loved ones
is unimaginable
so we turn to you God of all comfort and
ask that you be close to people in the
days ahead and that they might know your
peace that surpasses all understanding
for those who have lost homes and
livelihoods
Lord God we pray for those who have lost
their homes and liveliness or have been
moved to safety away from tall buildings
please keep them warm in the midst of
the harsh winter and provide for them
all they need
we pray especially for children who are
confused and frightened by what is
happening may you be for them an oasis
of Peace in which to take shelter
amen
and for those agencies that have gone in
to help
Lord we thank you for the Swift action
of those who are already responding for
the rescue team searching for survivors
we ask for them endurance and resilience
for those providing temporary shelter we
pray for the Swift Delivery of equipment
and for all those in communities
offering comfort and help to their
neighbors we pray that you give them
selfless compassion
oh man
if you know the words and you would like
to join in then feel free to join me in
saying the Lord's Prayer
Our Father which art in heaven Hallowed
be thy name thy kingdom come thy will be
done on Earth as it is in heaven give us
this day our daily bread and forgive us
our trespasses as we forgive them that
trespass against us and lead us not into
temptation but Deliver Us from Evil for
thine is the kingdom the power and the
glory forever and ever amen
and at this time we're going to uh have
a minute silence if you're able to those
of you who are sitting would you mind
standing because we're going to have a
minute silence in remembrance of
colleagues who have recently died
we remember our colleagues Michelle
power and a previous offer and
ex-counselor Roland Adams we remember
them and we hold their families before
God that they may know his peace and so
a minute silence
and the blessing of God Almighty the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit be
with you and all whom you love this
night and forevermore
amen
thank you Kim as always you are welcome
to stay but I know you do have a very
busy diary but and so if you want to
disappear please feel free thank you
thank you members public please be
seated
okay
members of the public
was Europe
while you are of course entitled to film
or take photographs during this meeting
can you please can I please emphasize
to you that this should be done without
disruption to the meeting and only can I
can only be done from the designated
area in the public seating
can I please therefore ask you to raise
your hand clearly in the air if you wish
to take photographs or you are filming
this evening
thank you
members
when I invite you to speak
please wait until there is a microphone
in front of you
before speaking
as microphones are needed for the
hearing Loop and the audio recording
they are all switched on and ready for
you to speak
so that you do not need to adjust them
please make sure the microphone is in
directly in front of you before speaking
members voting will be done by a show of
hands in line with the Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands
four
then against
recommendations and then for abstaining
given the size of the room and the
numbers are present
can I please ask that you put your hands
up clearly
high in the air
so it can easily be seen
by although or by all
and leave it up
until I ask you to lower it
the normal rules of debate apply
no members should speak for longer than
five minutes
and I can
and can I please ask you not to repeat
anything previously said
all those indicating to speak will be
given an opportunity to speak once
members can I just remind you if you
wish to speak again please put your hand
up clearly in the air and neither I
or the vice chair will make a note
when they've noted it down they will ask
you to lower your hand but please make
sure that it's clear
okay item one apologies
apologies have been received from
councilors butcher Mrs got Gooding Mr
James Gooding
Council ambourne and councilor Wilkinson
councilor June Lumley and councilor
David Sharp are there any others
Carson Newport thank you chairman
councilor Andrew cross
okay that will be noted
team members uh right members are you
happy for me to sign the minutes
agenda item two held on the 13th of
December
is that agreed members
cool
members item three
Declarations of Interest
Castle Newport
um thank you chairman as a member of
Essex County Council I'd like to declare
a non-pecuniary interest in item eight
please
thank you Council Newport for the record
I also need to declare the same
declaration with regards to council item
eight
councilor Mrs Shaw
thank you chairman I also want to do a
non-precunitary interest for itemate as
for yourself and councilor Newport thank
you
Council Ahoy
Essex County Council can you say can you
repeat that because the mic wasn't on
sorry I had no security interest in the
in the same other Essex County
councilors as a member of Essex County
Council thank you
are there any other declarations
okay that's good
gender item four announcements from the
chairman leader and head of paid service
members
since our last full council meeting
2023 is in full swing
and I've already retained attended many
engagements in the community
I had the privilege of attending my
Civic service
where I joined the community in prayer
and reflection
it was a beautiful uplifting experience
that reminded us of the importance of
coming together in times of both Joy and
hardship
I was able to celebrate
now I'm going to pronounce this wrong
the Sacra Festival recently at Swain
School
with members of the local Indian
Community
it was Lively noisy Festival occasion
the coast showcased the rich cultural
heritage of our community
the members it's the biggest
game of musical chairs I have ever seen
there must have been a hundred people to
start with
all of the ladies
it was my honor to attend the Local
District Business Awards where we
recognized and celebrated the
achievements of some of our most
successful business successful and
initiative
businesses
it was inspiring to see how the hard
work and dedication
that goes into building a successful
business
and the positive impact that they have
on our community
our Holocaust Memorial Day service took
place at the end of January
here at the Mill Hall
we're remembered and paid homage to the
millions of victims
of one of the darkest moments in the
human history
it was a somber
but employment important reminder
of the atrocities that humanity is
capable of and the importance of
standing up for justice and human rights
I would also like to take this
opportunity to invite invite you all to
join me in the upcoming Civic dinner
where you will have the opportunity to
the honors on honor the winners of the
centers of the Year Awards
the event is a chain chart
this event is a chance for us to come
together as a community and celebrate
the achievements of some of the most
successful citizens
I hope to see many of you there
is there any announcements from the
leader
Kevin
and how to pay services
thank you Mr chairman no announcements
thank you thank you
okay members agenda item five
to note the minutes of the executive and
committee meetings held between the
period first of December 2022 and 31st
of January 2023
are these so native members
gender item six
Business from The Last council meeting
members does anyone have any questions
relating to the business from the
council meeting held on the 13th of
December 2022.
okay
gender item seven
ports on urgent decisions there are none
gender item eight
introduction of the separate food waste
collection
the report will be introduced by the
portfolio holder for environment
councilor Sperry
thank you chairman
members
you should all have the opportunity to
read a very comprehensive and in-depth
report by Mr hotton hopefully it covers
most of the questions that you are
likely to have but having said that I'll
just cover a few aspects
food separate segregation from green
waste has been passed by government it
is legislation so it is something we are
obliged to do
for some while Mr Hutton and myself have
been discussing the timing of the
introduction to this aspect
obviously with the transfer from sewage
to Rochford North we wanted to make sure
that that system settled down
comfortably before we started
introducing any further changes we are
now comfortable as our North that we
have reached that position and that we
can move on to introduce this latest
alteration that as I say we are obliged
to do
the
whole aspect of this will take some time
we know there we will be at least a
six-month build up on the time that is
needed for the introduction of new
trucks and lorries so you know it's not
going to be a five minute thing we have
the experience of North to support us
have already introduced this in other
councils across the country so it's
nothing new for them and we can learn
from their experience and some of the
should we say mishaps that they've been
exposed to along the way
I would like to give you everybody the
opportunity to ask myself and Mr Hutton
any questions and after that and
following this presentation after the
questions hopefully you will have seen
the recommendations on pages 8.8 and 8.9
of this report and if you are in
agreement we'll support the
recommendations thank you chairman
thank you chair a note in on page 8.7
the Section 8 the environmental
implications understand that the
expectation is to run with diesel
vehicles
um but it does actually say in the same
paragraph there that the purchase of
these vehicles May hinder the ability of
the council to achieve the target of Net
Zero carbon by 2023 can uh the portfolio
please explain the rationale behind
diesel as in preference to Electric
thank you if I'm a chairman I'll let Mr
hot and ask that this one is because we
count on to these more technical aspects
make sure you get the full correct
answers thank you chairman
Mr help
thank you it's uh it's not such a
preference it's what's pragmatic at this
time so I think the other paragraph
below obviously states that the depot is
capable of supplying enough Electric
Supply to charge uh at a whole Fleet of
electric vehicles there's also a view
that we may want to move Depots at some
point in the future to ensure that we
can charge an entirely so there's a
thought that um to invest in electric
fleets at this time would not be cost
effective there's also the opportunity
and something that will come forward at
later date is around what they call HBO
fuel which has a 90 reduction of carbon
impacts in the environments and that's
due to the fact that we can use these
sort of biodiesel which is a kind of
bridge between the two so I think that's
something we want to bring back to the
council for consideration there
obviously always is a financial impact
to doing these things but I think at the
moment we're just trying to keep the
issues separate I thought it was right
to flag up that it could possibly hinder
our ability to make the 2030s I'm not
saying it will but I'm just saying it
may do so thank you
next question Castle sparing I need to
ask you do you have a second for your
proposition
I
uh councilor Waldorf second chairman
yeah I formally second okay
Council Ahoy
thank you
um
the first question is obviously through
the chairman Council Sperry this is
referring to the
kitchen waste
can he confirm that the garden waste
collections will continue throughout
23-24 and Kenny also confirm whether
they will continue thereafter uncharged
I've got another question off that do
you want the question now yes please
yeah
um
my concerns for this I mean I'm for it
because it's legislation but my concerns
are about contamination given the waste
contract we have at the moment where
everything goes into the one beam what
have Norse experienced that and what
were their views on that thank you
yeah
thank you chairman it I'll take the the
first one yes the waste system will
continue as it currently is whether this
charging is not for this meeting I'm
afraid counselor hi that's for another
day
um but I could quite easily Give You Up
scenarios where both options apply we
you know as well as I do there are
districts around us who do charge and
there are other districts who don't
charge but that's going to be down for
the council to make that decision in due
course
over to Mr Hutton to take the second
question part of the question
thank you I mean North still have the
experience but I think we also have
experience their neighbors so if you
take um modern Castle point and Basin
they've all had um co-mingled
um garden and food which are now
separate services in the last two to
three years so Basin and actually going
for the experience now so they're
actually sort of um collecting separate
foods the last six months more than
previously around about 18 months ago
Castle point about three years ago so we
speak regularly to all three of those we
lean on their their experience but
certainly um in in all exams I wouldn't
say that there is always a risk of
contamination I think it's been viewed
as successful overall across all three
of those authorities where they've
separated the two streams out thank you
councilman Mrs Mason is next on my list
thank you chair
um the report cover or doesn't show I've
got some notes here to forgive me it's
difficult with these
um and he joined up thinking with other
departments in my view or alternative
considerations to those recommended
I would ask that the appropriate officer
and portfolio holders explore the
suitability of food euraters in New
builds and consideration to the
effectiveness of grants for retrofitting
because that would reduce the need for
us to have diesel lorries collecting
food waste and that hasn't that
consideration hasn't been mentioned
or explored it may not be viable but I
do think that it should be looked at so
I would ask that that's looked at please
the other concern I have is with the
recommendations
recommendations six and seven
give Authority dedicated authority to
the directory environment and the
portfolio holder
for environment
this is a significant decision
it's an important decision
and this Council should have learned in
my experience how important it is to
have full debate and full consultation
before things are implemented and I
would like those removed and that the
recommendation that the department uh
sorry director of environment in
conjunction with the portfolio holder
for the environment present their
conclusions to full Council so that this
Council can approve the decision thank
you
okay
tell us the story did you want to come
back on any of that
do you want to say the bid on the Retro
retrofitting and I'll do the the other
part
okay I think if it's if we can do it
we'll consider it no doubt about that I
don't think it's really an option in a
lot of places I think the places it
could be fitted is not going to have a
significant effect on the overall need
that we will have to have separate waste
collection we will still need to make
the commitment for trucks one thing
another I I'd like to think that the
debate we are having now will eliminate
the need to come back repeatedly to get
further consideration the figures are
quite clearly stated in the papers what
is involved what we need to do uh we'd
like to crack on with this chairman if
we could it's a statutory requirement by
law it's not as though we've got a got
any option on this this has got to
happen
um I don't know if that's enough for
council Mrs Mason or if you want to want
more okay
Mr Halton do you want to come back on
the other part
uh certainly that's obviously the
delegation needs to allow us to sort of
move at some Pace I think the um the
only issue would be is if we're bringing
back further reports on this matter then
um the ability to actually secure the
older vehicles and their own caddies
would have to be delayed of course until
that final decision was made upon those
reports so in a sense we will just lose
that momentum and time and so so the
idea perhaps introducing uh in in the
Autumn you'd be then looking to see that
slip perhaps to December or even into
the new year if a report has to come
back in while negotiations are ongoing
thank you
okay Council let me see Mason did you
want to come back yes I would like to
um I think Council sparing for accepting
the investigation into the food
iterators I wasn't talking about a great
deal of retro fitting I was talking
about primarily on new Estates because
that would totally eliminate the need
for the collections on those Estates
certainly I think that should be looked
at and I think it should be looked at in
conjunction with our planning department
um
I'm afraid I disagree with the office so
if it's so urgent why is there no
timeline in the report
we've got to come back by August 23. we
will have Council meetings in that time
I I do feel very strongly that this
Council should be the chamber where
decisions are made in the full knowledge
of all the information and I I will not
be
supporting this report if it continues
with item six and seven I'm sorry to say
that but I can't thank you
Mrs Mason
um just before I go to council Mrs
Wilson I'd like to bring in the Andrew
Hunkin I'll come back to you a second
a chairman I'd like to ask councilor
Christine Mrs Christine Mason please to
just uh EX to set out in a bit more
detail what her amendment is to this
recommendation six and seven so we can
record that please
yes certainly that the final
recommendations from the director of
environment in conjunction with the
portfolio holder for the environment
represented to Fourth Council for
approval thank you
and perhaps if time is of the essence a
timeline in reports would be quite
helpful in future thank you
Mrs Mason do you have a second for that
yep okay Council Sperry and you wanted
to come in
thank you chairman I as I mentioned
earlier we would have bought this
forward before the simple reason it
hasn't been brought forward earlier was
because of the transfer from sewers to
what is now Rochford North
if Mr hartner myself had had our our way
we would have done it bought it forward
in 2022
unfortunately we needed to make sure
Prudence due care due diligence make
sure that the transfer with Rochford
North was running smoothly before we
bought this forward we have liaised with
our partners
on this and we feel this is the right
time if members feel that uh
we are not uh responsible enough to if
we have any concerns to come back then
I'm sorry I'm very disappointed about
that but there is nothing Sinister about
this we just need to crack on and get
this situation moving we could find with
other councils across the country having
to do the same thing that we will end up
sitting or waiting for equipment the
trucks one thing another and the smooth
transition that we were hoping for may
not happen thank you chairman
members can I just remind you we now
have an amendment on the table
so those are now going I'm going to call
to speak need to speak to the amendment
not to the original proposal
so
I'll go to Mr councilor Mrs Wilson did
you wish to speak to the amendment or do
you want to hold until we've had the
vote number
Council of Newport is that the same
situation with you
okay
council Mrs Belton are you speaking to
the amendment
so but correct me if I'm wrong when I
start speaking
um
I can't support the amendment because it
states in the report that the figures
are in the report and there's talk of a
grant from Essex County Council for
moving um ahead with this this year and
it's my belief that a detailed report
has been put in front of us with figures
the portfolio holder and the officer are
merely asking to make the negotiations
to put these steps in actions they're
not looking for anything in additional
to anything in addition to what's
already in the report and it will be
very difficult to start negotiations if
there isn't an agreement from this
Council that we're ready to move forward
I just think it's an unnecessary
additional step in the process we're
debating this evening the figures are
here we've all had time to read it so I
can't support the amendment
thank you
Cass La Hoy are you speaking to the
amendment
uh thank you chairman
I think normally I would probably
support um councilor Mason in this
because I'm
very much in favor of democracy at work
um I think this is
perhaps a case which is unusual it's
we've had the way strategy we've fed
into the way strategy the way strategy
feeds into this report this report has
the figures in it it has how it's going
to work and as I see it six and seven
are really just the very final parts of
agreeing the contracts effectively
signing it
um
if it goes outside those figures I can't
see how that they could continue with it
and it would have to be brought back to
the council then anyway because we've
only agreed what's in this report so
they can't go beyond that or outside of
that so on this occasion I won't I can't
support the amendment
okay thank you Floyd
councilor Mrs McPherson
Mr chairman
that's easier um I think Council Mr
Hoyas just said a lot of what I wanted
to say but I do want to ask um if there
is a delay can officers advise if there
could be penalties or fines to our
accounts so if this was delayed thank
you
foreign
[Music]
thank you very much
um there wouldn't be penalties as such
no I mean the the key thing is that um
and there is a matter of time there's
one case
um sentence there within the procurement
sort of paragraphs and that says there's
a good at least six month leading time
on on the vehicles so if we do delay on
making decisions tonight then the order
can't be placed so so once that Council
before come you've had to come back in
only then could I replace it order it's
too much of a commitment to make until
we know that the council have given the
000 Capital that we're requesting uh you
know you could only place the order once
those those six and seven have been
agreed as well thank you
um thank you chairman so in effect there
could be an impact on our Council if we
do delay thank you
okay members is it a councilor fdu speak
to the amendment
thank you chairman
um just
we're debating this now this has options
in the reports which are quite clearly
stated also if another report was to
come back to council a question for Mr
Olson would it greatly differ from the
report we have now
so if I can have an answer on that
because
it's about the debate thank you Council
white Mr Holton would you wish to answer
that
thank you um I wouldn't anticipating it
changing um drastic I mean I mean I mean
it would be the detail that would come
back in terms of um so you'd be looking
at the sort of um and previously we
haven't brought that sort of before so
it would be the 77 agreement with
Rochford North that would be presenting
back which we're doing you know a
subsection referring to food collection
whereas um we have not brought that
forward before that was delegated before
for us to sort of um negotiate and
settle thanks
is there any other members wish to speak
to the amendment
okay members uh that amendment is before
you uh those who are in favor please
indicate
thank you those against
okay thank you members uh any
abstentions
okay could I have the numbers please
okay that's eight four
21 against two absentions that Amendment
fails
and I'll go back to the original
proposal and I go back to my original
list uh councilor Mrs Wilson
thank you chair my question is uh I
think for Mr Horton sorry Marcus
um
a reasonably minor Point possibly but
actually quite important
um I'm aware of these food caddies and
they were rolled out in the Basildon
area last October caused a lot of um
concern as to how that was going to work
can I just say it actually works very
well
my question is
there is no mention of it in this item
on the agenda
but our compostable bags going to be
supplied with the caddies
and used on an ongoing basis
because I happen to know resident in
Basildon who has run out of compostable
bags and food waste in a plastic box
even during winter is exceedingly
unpleasant and messy hence my question
thank you
Mr Horton would you like to respond
I think initially no we're proposing not
to I think that's because as an
authority we already do collect food and
then put into a larger bin but
nevertheless the ministers have food
caddies in the houses already so I think
it's it's something that it's not so
much
um the separation of food in the house
itself it's just how it's presented
curbside I think it's what we're
concentrating on thank you
thank you uh councilor Newport
thank you chairman
um
read it through the report I I actually
was quite disappointed in the vagueness
of much of it one of the um
I think councilor Reeves has already
said about the diesel trucks
as um councilor sparing said earlier
about cracking on with things I don't
really understand why
um we haven't cracked on and put the
infrastructure in place so we could have
electric vehicles
there's a lot of vagueness around
whether or not the depot will move
there's no timeline the environmental
implications if I just pick up on that
um it talks in there about buying diesel
trucks and then I think
um maybe retrofitting them with a
electric engine later on but I thought
that would have a
um a carbon impact as well
we don't see any comparisons between
um the Alternatives as in buying
electric trucks and what the impact that
would be on our carbon
um emissions
we're putting basically there's this
proposal is to put another four
diesel trucks on the road emitting
particle matter
into residence lungs
there's a big government push
on cutting down on particle matter
and I don't think this is the way to go
I think
the electric vehicles have been brushed
aside
in favor of the diesel but I don't see
any justification for that other than we
don't have the infrastructure available
in the depot and I don't think that's a
good enough reason because I think we
could have easily have done that by now
when this waste strategy came out 2022 I
think councilor sparing said that this
we knew that we were going to have to do
this the trucks are smaller from my
understanding in this report and I think
they could be feasible
so I'm really disappointed in this
report
thank you
curse of Spain just before you are
answer there if I can press just add a
point to councilor newport's question
there will the trucks be of the latest
specification with the latest Euro
particulate type filters that are now
required
I believe that is the case Mr Hutton
just not in an agreement that is correct
chairman with regard to the depot
it didn't really want to get into this
tonight because it's not a decision for
tonight but we are being pushed quite
heavily by County to have a new combined
Depot the one we have currently is not
fit for purpose any longer we have as I
understand it on an issue with Electric
Supply into the depot itself so actually
charging the vehicles we have had and we
are very fortunate to have our friends
at Knowles giving us advice on the sort
of trucks that are needed the costings
and the durability and at the moment
from the Expressions that we're getting
I think Mr hartner myself would be very
unhappy to go out and purchase electric
vehicles because they do not yet have
the proven track record we know other
councils have gone out and purchased
these but as I say talking to our
colleagues at Norse they are very I
think wary concerned the track record is
not there at the moment and we don't
want to go out and purchase these
vehicles only to find that we run into
maintenance issues and other aspects if
we've said it made it quite clear that
if further down the road we can transfer
onto electric vehicles we will do we're
not being negative we're just trying to
make sure that we get the right vehicles
at this time thank you chairman
Stone
okay is there anybody else wish to ask
I'll raise a question on this item
okay right I move forward to the
recommendations
I will read them out
and they're set but they are set out on
page
8.9
starting at paragraph 12.1
all right it says 8.9 of my sheep
but yes I think you're correct it starts
at 8.8 onto 8.9
okay uh item one recommendation one
the weekly collection of food waste be
introduced in Autumn 2023
item two the connect containers provided
to the households for food waste are 23
liter curbside food caddies
that item three no that 910
000 be drawn down from a capital
expenditure as outlined in the report
item four that the additional net
forty thousand pound Revenue budget be
provided for the delivery of food waste
collection services in 2023-24
item five the consultation be undertaken
in seeking the views of the households
on options for the change to Future
waste collections services
item six that the authority be delegated
to the director of environment in
consultation with the portfolio holder
for environment to finalize the business
case
and consequent Arrangement agreement
with Essex County Council regarding the
introduction of the separate food Waste
Service
item seven that the authority be
delegated to the director of environment
in consultation with the portfolio
holder for environment
to undertake the con contract
negotiations with Rochford noise North
joint venture to finalize the necessary
changes to the collections and services
members are you happy that I take the
recommendations on block
okay members we have won against so I
have to go back
item by item
okay
item one
that the weekly collection of food waste
been introduced in Autumn 2023 those in
favor
thank you members that is unanimous
item two
the containers provided to the
households for food waste are 23 liter
curbside
food caddies those in favor
okay
second members
those against
and is anyone abstaining
why not saying
okay members we have 34
and one extension
as Carrie
yeah
no
okay item three
that nine hundred and ten thousand be
drawn down
for the capital from for the capital
expenditure as outlined in the report
those in favor
keep your hands up please
okay
thank you members
any against
any abstentions
okay that's 28 4 and 3 extensions
okay item four
that the additional net forty thousand
Revenue budget be provided
for delivery of the food waste
collection service in 2023 to 2024
those in favor
okay thank you members
goes against
any abstentions
okay that's 29 for two abstentions that
is carried
item five
the consultation behind the taken in
seeking the views of households on
operations for change to the Future
waste collection service
those in favor
thank you members that's unanimous
item six
but the authority
excuse me
that the authority be delegated to the
director of environment in consultation
with the portfolio holder for
environment to find the finalize the
business case
because
consequent agreement with Essex County
Council regarding the introduction of a
separate food Waste Service
those in favor
thank you members
does against
any abstentions
okay that's 21-4
8 against two abstentions that's carried
item seven
that Authority be delegated to the
director of environment in consultation
with a portfolio holder for the
environment to undertake contract
negotiations with Rochford noise with
Rachel North joint venture to finalize
the necessary changes to the collection
service
those in favor
thank you members
those against
any abstentions
okay thank you members
okay that's 21-4
seven against and three abstentions
thank you items carried members thank
you
okay
okay members moving on to agenda item
nine
the local council tax support scheme
members the report will be introduced by
the portfolio holder for finance economy
and climate councilor Mrs Belton
thank you chair
this report sets out the local tech
support scheme for 23.24 there are
currently
3640 households that receive 4 million
in support from this scheme
some counselors may remember that in
April 22 the council changed the scheme
so that it's simpler for customers to
use and also simpler to administer there
are a few households that lost out as a
direct result of the changes so this
Council provided transitional relief to
those residents in 2022-23
it is proposed to continue that
transitional relief in 23-24.
we will also be administered in
administering up to 25 pounds to all
council tax support claimants funded
from Central governments council tax
support fund
in addition to this the council operates
an exceptional hardship fund for those
claimants that can demonstrate
particular hardship in paying their
council tax
there are two recommendations listed at
8.1 on 9.4 page 9.4 thank you
do you have a second there for your
property
chairman I'd like to second that
does anybody wish to speak to this
Council Ahoy
casner can you use microphone thank you
um just very brief to say I was in
support of the changes last year and I'm
very pleased that they're continuing
this year including the removal of the
minimum income floor for the
self-employed thank you thank you
anybody else wish to speak
councilor Mrs Mason
uh thank you yes I just say that I'd
like to support this and I'm pleased to
know that the discretionary transitional
arrangements are continuing I think that
would be a great relief to our residents
thank you
anybody else
thank you members
okay there are two
recommendations for this
uh set out at parallel 8.1 on page 9.4
of the report
I'll read them out
item one
that the
lcts scheme be confirmed from the 1st of
April 2023
item two
that the proposed changes to
discretionary reduction in council tax
liability policy be approved from the
1st of April 2023.
yeah
okay members I'm advised we need to do
both separately
so the first one
that the lcts scheme be confirmed from
the 1st of April
2023 those in favor
thank you members that's unanimous
item two
the proposed changes to the
discretionary reduction in council tax
liability policy be approved on the 1st
of April 2023.
those in favor
thank you members that's game is
unanimous
okay members moving on to agenda item
10.
one team transformation program
strategic partnership with Brentwood
Borough Council
member the report will be introduced by
the council director of policy and
delivery Craig Campbell
thank you chairman good evening members
as part of the requirements of the
partnership we report quarterly to the
scrutiny committee and we have to
provide an annual report to this Council
this is the first annual report to this
Council that is before you this evening
it provides an overview of the costly
reports and it updates you on progress
that has been made with one team and the
partnership between Rochford and
Brentwood you'll see that progresses be
made on the governance Arrangements
you'll see that progress has been made
on the structure between tiers one to
three service reviews have begun and we
are making inroad into some of the other
areas where we can undertake some joint
working the report is before you uh to
be noted thank you chairman thank you
members
members is there any wishbody wish to
comment or raise questions on this
councilor Mrs Mason
all right thank you just a couple of
points that I'd like perhaps to be
included
um in future on page 10.7
we've got resident feedback now I
appreciate that a report is given to the
ons committee on a culturally basis but
that's not all counselors so I wondered
if there's an opportunity perhaps to get
some member feedback as well as
residence feedback to find out how
members are appreciating the
differential
administrative structures I think that
would be helpful for all
so that's just one point if you could
consider in future and the second point
we we have a summary of benefits in this
report which is quite comprehensive
but we haven't got the alternative
I would expect to see
a slightly more balanced
um
pros and cons if you like
so I wonder
if in future reports and I appreciate
this is the first one so I'm not
criticizing it I'm just asking for it to
be elaborated and I know there are some
some of that information on the negative
side is in the report the body of the
report but I wonder if we could just
have two tables for comparison and I
would say that when you're looking at
positives and negatives that they're not
always going to be Financial
so that would be helpful for us to see
in the future but other than that I've
got no questions thank you
Council Ahoy
thank you chairman just a very brief one
um item 90 quality on diversity
implications
it states that equality impact
assessments will be undertaken as part
of any service review that would affect
or change the services being provided
surely we should do this for services
that should remain the same or cannot
have confirmation that the service
Services which remain the same have
already had
inequality and diversity impact
assessment
Campbell would you like to comment on
that
thank you chair and thank you councilor
Hoy I can confirm that that is correct
if we are the services remaining the
same that would still be carried out at
the same point while we're doing the
review and the quality impact
assessments have been carried on out on
the two services so far that we've
reviewed
okay and can I just confirm that the
points that councilor Mrs Mason raised
uh you have duly noted
thank you
anybody else
councilor wooden
thank you chairman on page 10.10
4.2 it refers to a full benefits table
being drawn together I just wonder
whether we could have clarification as
to a timeline as to when that will be
available please thank you chairman
thank you chairman thank you leader I I
would hope for that to be ready and
available at the next quarter so we are
developing at the moment it is uh nearly
there we just need to finish off some
extra lines and bring things together
anybody else
okay members
um quite simple on this one uh that the
report an update in progress in year one
be noted is that noted members
thank you
okay agenda item 11
allocation of seats on committees
members you will have received an email
from democratic services to advise you
that this item of business has been
deferred and will now be considered at
the meeting on the 21st of February
we will that
therefore move on to item 12 of the
agenda
item 12 reports from the executive and
committees to the council
members we have a report from the
overview and scrutiny committee on the
capital and treasury treasury management
strategy 2023-24
members the report will be introduced by
the chairman of overview and security
committee councilor Wilson
Council Wilson
chairman the overdose
on the 1st of February
can you hold the mic a little closer
it's quite funny
it is on it's on
sorry chairman the overview and scrutiny
committee met on the 1st of February and
unanimously agreed the following one
that the capital and treasury management
strategy statement including the
investment instruments indicators limits
and delegations contained within the
report be noted
two that the capital expenditure
forecast being noted
three that the operational and
authorized limits for external debt has
laid down in the report be noted
and four that the capital and treasury
management strategy for 2023 2024 are
set out in the report be approved
thank you Council Wilson do you have a
second for that
okay so let me see my face
thank you chairman I will second that
okay
okay members any questions
probably wish to raise any points
okay members
there are four items that Council Wilson
has just read out I won't read them out
again
and
those in favor
thank you members that's unanimous
members
a gender item 13 report of the leader on
the work of the executive
members is this noted
kill
item 14.
okay
okay item 14 is public questions and
members questions on notice
members we have received two public
questions on notice
members I will now invite
Mr John Payton to read out his question
to the leader
can you hear me
thank you chair thank you Council and
thank you to the leader for taking the
question
this is the question to the leader
councilor Simon Wootton
the leader of the council has publicly
stated that the council was Visionary in
recognizing Financial challenges facing
local government the council needed to
press ahead with cost efficiencies by
maximizing use of the council's assets
and the council has a long-standing
proven history of prudent and
responsible financial management and
that will continue to be the continuing
theme of the administration despite
current challenges
however this Administration has overseen
1.6 million pounds and Rising for costs
for the asset delivery program
including 622 000 pounds in penalties
paid to the development partner GB
Partnerships for the removal of Mill
Hall from the program and over 460 000
paid Consultants
as of this date there appears to be
nothing to show for the troubling waste
of public funds Mill Hall is now
additionally facing hundreds of
thousands of pounds of remedial
refurbishment costs
in response to the 6th of December 2022
executive meeting to counselor Chris
Stanley's question why has RDC not
pressed Fusion to meet these obligations
in the upkeep of Mill Hall the leader
responded I can confirm that Fusion
remains responsible for repair and
ongoing maintenance of the mill and this
Council will continue to ensure that
Fusion carry out the responsibilities to
maintain the building
yet at a meeting of the overview and
scrutiny committee on the 1st of
February 2023 Phoebe Barnes the director
for assets investment confirmed the
backlog of maintenance issues were
waived as part of the variation of the
Leisure contract with Fusion
in March 2021 the leader said publicly I
think with the outsourced provider
Fusion I'm not sure that they've
maintained it to perhaps the desired
level looking back I would accept that
there hasn't been good enough investment
does the leader agree that his answer on
the 6th of December is in contradiction
to the statement by the director for
assets and investment and will he agree
that by his own words his administration
failed to enforce the terms of the
Lesser contract which in turn has led to
significant public Financial losses
thank you miss Peyton thank you very
much
Council Wooten would you please respond
to the question
thank you chairman I wonder whether I
might break with protocol and address Mr
Payton from the lectern but that does
break protocol by turning my back on you
I'm afraid not uh um I wouldn't know
everything has to be addressed through
me so that's absolutely fine absolutely
fine chairman no problem at all uh
excuse me Mr Payton if I'm not able to
uh look at you directly and the and the
audience at the back
um but thank you very much indeed Mr
Payton for your question and I genuinely
appreciate the opportunity to reply to
you
one of our key strategic priorities as a
council is to continue to transform
ourselves into a modern accessible and
financially sustainable Council
delivering excellent value for money
services to Residents and businesses in
the district
an integral part of that is to maximize
the use of our buildings estate through
a program of rationalization and
modernization and with that in mind the
asset delivery program was created
it needs to be made clear that the
program includes buildings on six sites
in the district which were not fit for
their intended purpose in their current
state for a variety of reasons and very
costly to maintain
the male Hall arts and Event Center was
just one of those sites in 2019 the
business case for the ADP was very clear
build to new Council offices in Rochford
provide a new community center in
Rayleigh dispose of surplus buildings
regenerate and bring much needed
affordable housing into the district
in 2019 the net costs of the project
were 1.6 million with annual Savings of
around three hundred thousand pounds per
annum
to embark on any ambitious program of
this nature there is a need to commit to
considerable upfront expenditure with
the need of consultants and experts not
least to comply with local government
procurement rules
much has happened outside of the
council's control since 2019 to change
thinking including a massive increase in
building costs less need for office
space as a result of hybrid and smart
ways of working our strategic
partnership with Brentwood Borough
Council and of course public feedback
where particularly in radio there was
little appetite from residents to
replace the Mill Hall arts and events
center with a new Community Hall
contrary to what was said at that time
we have listened paused and reflected
and taken difficult decisions
so to put it into context and with that
background in mind turning to your
specific question tonight my answer on
the 6th of December is not a
contradiction
far from it
the council's contract with Fusion was
varied in 2020 due to the mounting
pressures of the pandemic on the Leisure
industry
this enables Clements Hall Leisure
Center and radio Leisure Center to
remain open the Mill arts and Event
Center has been mothballed
as it was proposed for development as
part of the council's asset delivery
program
due to the expectation of the mill arts
and Event Center being developed with a
new sustainable Community Hall the new
agreement with Fusion was to continue to
ensure it ensure the building was Secure
and safe and Carry Out essential
maintenance only
before the decision of the ADP Fusion
had delivered all capital works on the
building as part of their programmed
Works therefore this council did ensure
the obligations of the previous contract
were upheld and this Council continues
to ensure all obligations of revised
contracts are upheld
the agreed Capital works in the varied
contract with Fusion were for Clements
Hall Leisure Center and ready Leisure
Center only the major Capital works of
the building became the council's
responsibility when it took the decision
to reopen the mill arts and events
center
regarding the figures quoted in your
question can I please remind you that
these figures are not solely for the
mill arts and event center but relate to
all six sites proposed for the
development as part of the council's
asset delivery program
as part of the program we have
successfully got planning permission for
40 residential units across South Street
and the Civic Center this program is
achieving our goal of providing much
needed new sustainable residential homes
in the district as well as enhanced
office space at The Freight House in
Rochford
the 622 000 pounds is a costing specific
to specific to the mill arts and Event
Center
it is due to the executive listening to
the views of residents and in part is
also the result of responding to the
wishes of those associated with the Save
The Mill Hall campaign by taking it out
of the ADP and reopening it
to have pressed ahead with an
alternative scheme would for the reason
stated earlier have been far costlier
and not acceptable to the community
consequently the executive had to make
the difficult decision to use this
financial resource in order to give the
community what they said they wanted the
Miller arts and events center as it is
which we have done however this change
it to a commercial contract came with a
penalty that the council has paid and
accounted for within its finances
a building's problem built by beg your
pardon a buildings program of this kind
does not come without some risks the
exceptional circumstances of the past
few years could never have been foreseen
by anyone
the Dynamics and cost of this project
have changed massively in a relatively
short period of time
no one has behaved recklessly and
difficult decisions have had to be made
in the light of facts it is very easy to
comment from the sidelines and oppose
whatever Direction the project takes
using the knowledge and benefit of
hindsight
I accept that there are different points
of view and not everything has gone as
originally envisaged but in the light of
experience and feedback we are
absolutely determined to now make the
Mill Hall arts and events center a
vibrant place which the community can be
proud of and I will be providing more
detail of our proposed capital and
revenue expenditure over the coming days
Mr Payton given your clear passion and
interest rather than always focusing on
the past which I accept has caused some
justifiable concerns to you as well as
me I would urge you please along with
other community Representatives
particularly already to work
constructively with me my team and
officers in the council to make this
place a jewel in the crown of which the
Rochford District can be justified for
justifiably be proud thank you Mr
chairman yeah
thank you councilor Winton
next question comes from uh Ms Jill
White
I will now invite Mr Waite to read out
her question to the deputy leader
thank you chairman for this opportunity
to speak and uh congratulations to the
vice chair for our courage for becoming
independent
uh so my questions for the deputy leader
councilor Sheryl Rowe who's been a
member of the executive since 2014.
counselor Rowe at the executive
committee meeting on the 19th of January
with regard to continuing the lease of
and council's asset the Fairview
Pavilion you stated that monitoring
should take place to ensure that tenants
carried out essential maintenance and
repairs as per their contract this was
also noted in the meeting minutes
yet Council officers have admitted there
was a backlog of Maintenance that hadn't
been completed by the tenant responsible
for another Council asset the mill arts
and events center
this was despite regular site visits
inspections as well as operational and
strategic meetings with the tenant
how can residents have confidence in
this executive's asset monitoring
abilities when you've allowed the mill
arts and events centers long terms of
the coin decline to the point that you
personally staying to council row that
it was Dire and not fit for purpose that
does seem to be a phrase or was it a
deliberate strategy for the mill arts
and events center only were you trying
to ensure that the councils as it
disaster program sorry asset delivery
program will be accepted by the
residents thank you
thank you Miss White
council Mrs Rowe would you please
respond to the question
and thank you Jill waits for your
question
the purpose of the asset development
sorry the asset delivery program is to
create a program to deliver value for
money for the council
it is the council's responsibility to
make the most of its buildings to ensure
they continue to provide value for money
and to maximize their potential
this includes exploring opportunities
for stimulating regeneration and
economic growth
for the benefit of the district as a
whole
it makes sound financial sense for the
council to review the sites it owns
to ensure they are put to the best use
particularly as sites built a
considerable time ago costs The
Authority money to secure and to
maintain and are therefore not
financially or environmentally
sustainable
this is due to their age and the need
for significant investment
to continue to maintain them in the
future
in some instances it is more cost
beneficial to redevelop an asset for its
required purpose and future needs rather
than to retrofit retrofit it
this Council has ensured
that its assets portfolio isn't just fit
for purpose for now it is ensuring that
its asset portfolio offering is fit for
purpose for the future as well
therefore all the resource has gone into
the asset development program
is to demonstrate to Residents that the
council is actively taking
responsibility for its buildings looking
to stimulate regeneration and economic
growth for the benefits of the whole
District
difficult decisions have to be made in
reviewing the council's asset portfolio
but this Council has ensured the right
decisions have been made for the future
of this District thank you chairman
thank you council Mrs Rowe
members I will now move on to member
questions on notice
we have received one question on notice
from councilor Bob Mill
Casper Milne can I please ask you to
read out your question to the portfolio
holder for strategic planning and assets
we all know thank you chairman uh yes um
I was extremely disappointed at the ons
committee was unable owing to objections
which were upheld concerning the process
of the debate to make meaningful
recommendations because there were the
the item was deferred at their last
meeting to the executive members on the
day-to-day running in future and
sustainability of the mill arts and
events center
despite this can the portfolio holder
for a strategic
and assets provided reassurance and
confidence on his commitment to ensure
that the Mill Hall remains open and has
a viable and sustainable future for the
residents of Rayleigh and the district
as a whole thank you
counselor thank you counselor Mill
councilor Ian Ward would you please
respond to the question
thank you chairman
and thank you councilor Milne for that
question I know you have a great deal of
passion for the Mill Hall and have
voiced it quite strongly on occasions in
regards to its continuance this Council
took the decision after listening to its
community
to reopen The Mill Hall and this council
is committed to ensuring the building
remains open
The Mill Hall arts and Event Center was
opened on the 12th of September
officers worked tirelessly in opening
the building
and continue to work extremely hard
in keeping the building open for its
primary purpose
which is community use
however
the council operating the building is an
interim arrangement
the future operating model of the Mill
Hall arts and Event Center
was due to be scrutinized an overview
and scrutiny on the 1st of February
however as councilor Milne has pointed
out disappointingly this was deferred to
the 23rd of February
the purpose of this report is to be as
open and transparent on the financial
pressures the current building puts on
the council's budget
however it also highlights the next
steps this council is committed to
achieving to assure ensure the Mill Hall
arts and Event Center does have a viable
and sustainable future
we are committed to reducing the cost
pressures offering events that the
community want to attend and offering
services from this facility that the
community want to use
we want to hear from the community when
we develop the new business case
required on this building to demonstrate
how the Mill Hall arts and events center
can support the needs of our community
whilst reducing the financial pressures
thank you chairman
thank you Council Ward
councilor Milne do you have a
supplementary question
uh Mr chairman I do not
sorry
members
that concludes the the business for this
meeting but I would just like to take
this opportunity of thanking the number
of members of public coming along this
evening is always a great pleasure to
see you here and I hope you've uh well I
say enjoyed yourself I hope you've taken
on board some of the things we've said
members that can close this meeting and
I close the meeting
at by my watch at nine
55.
members please be upstanding for your
chairman